हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। तो सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे
रही है?
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है?
प्लीज चैट में बता दीजिए यस या नो।
प्लीज चैट में बता दीजिए सबको मेरी आवाज
सुनाई दे रही है?
ओके थैंक यू।
चलिए फिर थोड़ा सा वेट करें क्या?
ओके लाउड एंड क्लियर है ना? पहले की तरह
कोई इशू तो नहीं आया वॉइस के साथ? ओके।
चलो अच्छी बात है। कैसे हो आप लोग?
सब लोग बढ़िया हो?
बढ़िया। ओके गुड।
सबको
क्लास में मजा आ रहा है?
क्लासेस पसंद आ रही है सबको?
या आई एम फाइन जगत गुरु जी
चलिए तो दे आर टोटल 10 स्टूडेंट प्रीवियस
क्लास किस-किस ने देखी है लास्ट क्लास में
कौन-कौन था मेरी क्लास में बताओ लास्ट की
एक या दो क्लास में कौन-कौन था मे बी जगत
गुरु जी थे और कौन-कौन था बताओ जरा जरा
कौन-कौन था बताओ जरा
ओके और कौन था जगत गुरु जी के अलावा
क्या आप अकेले ही थे क्लास में बाकी कोई
नहीं था
बाकी कोई नहीं था।
तो चलो मैं सबसे कॉमन क्वेश्चन पूछना
चाहता हूं कि ओके दो स्टूडेंट्स थे। निखिल
था और ओके मान सिंह शर्मा
आफ्टर वेरी लॉन्ग टाइम
हाउ आर यू ब्रो
तो निखिल था, जगत गुरु जी थे। अगर मेरी कल
की क्लास में मतलब लास्ट टाइम जो क्लास
हुई थी सैटरडे और संडे में तो मुझे एक
फीडबैक चाहिए आप लोगों से और मैं सिर्फ
आपसे नहीं पूछ रहा जो भी क्लास खत्म होने
के बाद या अभी क्लास कंप्लीट हो जाती है
जो भी रिकॉर्डेड सेशन को देखने वाला है
बिल्कुल स्टार्टिंग से मुझे एक फीडबैक
चाहिए था और जो रिकॉर्डेड सेशन देख रहे
हैं वह कमेंट में फीडबैक दे सकते हैं कि
जो अभी मैं स्लाइड यूज कर रहा हूं कि जो
मैं प्रेजेंटेशन यूज कर रहा हूं आप लोगों
के
तो प्रेजेंटेशन में कुछ आपने देखा होगा
कुछ चेंजेस है अभी के सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
क्लास में इससे पहले चेंजज़ नहीं थे। लास्ट
की क्लास में चेंजज़ थे। लास्ट के दो क्लास
में चेंजज़ हुए हैं। चेंजेस क्या थे कि
उसमें मैं थोड़ा सा इनेटिव स्लाइड्स ऐड कर
रहा हूं। कुछ एनिमेशन के साथ और इनेटिव
स्लाइड्स है। मतलब बीच में कुछ एक जो मैं
पढ़ाना चाहता हूं जो आपको एनिमेट करवाना
चाहता हूं। वो बीच में एक स्टोरी टाइप का
एक इमेज रहती है। साइड में कुछ जनरल नॉलेज
होती है, जनरल अवेयरनेस होती है और कई
कबभार स्टेप्स होते हैं। ये चीजें होती
हैं। तो प्लीज मुझे फीडबैक ये चाहिए था
क्या ये चीज आपको अच्छी लग रही है या नहीं
लग रही? क्योंकि सभी क्लासेस के लिए ऐसा
नहीं होगा क्योंकि ओपन यह खास के जो हमारी
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग की क्लासेस है तो उसमें
इमेजिनेशन ज्यादा चाहिए होती है। तो तो
मैं सब यह जानना चाहता हूं कि क्या सबको
वो स्लाइड्स अच्छी लग रही है? अच्छी लग
रही है तो यस बता दीजिए। अगर नहीं भी लग
रही है तो नो करके बता दीजिए। मेरे को
एक्चुअल में आप लोगों से फीडबैक चाहिए कि
लाइव क्लास में जो आते हैं वो लाइव क्लास
में बता दीजिए। नहीं तो बाकी जो
रिकॉर्डिंग सेशन देखते हैं तो प्लीज मुझे
जो प्रेजेंटेशन है मेरी उसके ऊपर रिव्यू
चाहिए। सो दैट कि मैं नहीं चाहता कि अगर
आपको अच्छा नहीं लग रहा बोरिंग लग रहा है
या आप कोरिलेट नहीं कर पा रहे जो मैं बता
रहा हूं या चीजों को कोरिलेट नहीं कर पा
रहे तो मैं इनको नेक्स्ट टाइम से नहीं यूज
करूंगा क्योंकि इट इज वेरीेंट कि आप लोग
उस चीज को समझो। मैं अपने लिए नहीं बना
रहा। वह आप लोगों के लिए ही है।
बताओ
जगत गुरु जी ने बोला यस सही है बाकी
नहीं नहीं मैं बीच में नहीं रोका व हाफ पे
नहीं रोका फिन कॉमन बिकॉज़ क्लासेस में
काफी लॉन्ग टाइम से गैप हो गया था
प्रीवियस स्टूडेंट चले गए थे मुझे पता है
कि प्रीवियस स्टूडेंट नहीं आए हैं। तो मैं
उनको स्टॉप नहीं कर रहा। मैं फिर से
रिकंटिन्यू करूंगा बट राइट टाइम आने पर।
इसलिए मैंने नया टॉपिक स्टार्ट किया
क्योंकि बहुत सारे स्टूडेंट है उसको
कोरिलेट नहीं कर पाते। तो ये एक रीजन था
क्योंकि बाकी धीरे-धीरे जैसे कि
स्टूडेंट्स है बहुत सारे क्योंकि काफी
लॉन्ग टाइम था कि मैं काफी टाइम तक क्लास
नहीं ली थी फोर टू फाइव मंथ जिसकी वजह से
काफी बड़ा गैप हो गया था और बहुत सारे
स्टूडेंट चले गए थे।
इसी वजह से क्या हुआ कि मैं उसको स्टॉप
करके एक नया टॉपिक स्टार्ट करना पड़ा ताकि
जो प्रेजेंट स्टूडेंट है वह समझ पाए क्या
चीज चल रही है। उसके बाद हम उसको कंटिन्यू
कर लेंगे।
तो चलिए फिर सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं।
तो प्लीज मेरी आप लोगों से वही रिक्वेस्ट
है। प्लीज आप अपना रिव्यु जरूर दीजिए। ठीक
है? फीडबैक जरूर शेयर कीजिए। चाहे वो चैट
में शेयर कर सकते हो चाहे फिर आप लाइव
क्लास में शेयर कर सकते हो। चलिए जो आज का
हमारा टॉपिक है इट इज वेरी यूनिक एंड
एक्सट्रीमली क्रिटिकल और एक्सट्रीमलीेंट
और आज हम बात करने वाले हैं एथिकल एंड
लीगल कंसीडरेशंस इन सोशल इंजीनियरिंग।
देखो कई बार हम टूल्स और टेक्निक सीखने
में इतने खो जाते हैं कि हम भूल जाते हैं
कि ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी से खेलते वक्त और
उनकी मोरल बाउंड्रीज क्या है?
आई मीन कि हम हमेशा टूल्स और टेक्निक्स पर
ज्यादा ध्यान देते हैं। लेकिन जब बात आती
है सोशल इंजीनियरिंग की, सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
में हम क्या यूज करते हैं? ह्यूमन
साइकोलॉजी। ठीक है? सोशल इंजीनियरिंग में
क्या है? ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी का यूज़ करते
हैं। और ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी के साथ हम खेलते
हैं। और उसको खेलते वक्त हम उनकी जो मोराल
बाउंड्रीज होती हैं, उनको भूल जाते हैं।
उनकी मोरल बाउंड्रीज को क्रॉस कर जाते
हैं। ओके? तो आज के सेशन में हम सीखेंगे
कि कंपनी के एंप्लाइज का ट्रस्ट जो कंपनी
के एम्प्लई का ट्रस्ट गेन करते वक्त आपको
कहां रुकना है, कहां कंसेंट काम करता है
या कंसेंट क्या होता है? कंसेंट का मतलब
कहां परमिशन चाहिए होती है, कहां परमिशन
नहीं चाहिए होती और आप बिना किसी पर्सनल
नुकसान के आप अपना काम भी कंप्लीट कर
पाएं। मतलब मैं आपको समझाने की कोशिश
करूंगा कि जब आप सोशल इंजीनियरिंग परफॉर्म
करते हैं तो वहां पर आप एंप्लई के ट्रस्ट
के साथ खेलते हैं तो उसको कितने लेवल तक
खेलना है या किस लेवल तक उसको यूज करना है
कहां-कहां परमिशंस चाहिए होती हैं
ताकि आप जो भी काम करो आप एक तो आप अपना
काम कंप्लीट कर पाओ दूसरा बिना किसी
नुकसान के ओके बिना किसी नुकसान के। देखिए
हम सबको पता है सोशल इंजीनियरिंग में
लोगों को मैनपुलेट जो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
अटैक होता है उसमें लोगों को मैनपुलेट
किया जाता है। ठीक है? और क्या हर
मैनपुलेशन एथिकल है? आप ही बताओ। सबको पता
है इस बात का कि जो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग है
उसमें लोगों को मैनपुलेट किया जाता है। तो
क्या हर मैनपुलेशन एथिकल है?
नहीं। हर एक मैनपुलेशन एथिकल नहीं होती।
और एक प्रोफेशनल एनवायरमेंट में आपको किन
रूलों को ध्यान रखना चाहिए? किन चीजों के
बारे में आपको पता होना चाहिए? क्या करना
है, क्या नहीं करना है? ताकि
आप लोग किसी मुसीबत में ना फंसे। बिकॉज़ एज
ए पेंटेस्टर्स यू आर द फ्रंट सबसे फ्रंट
में आप ही लोग होंगे। किसी भी कंपनी की
सिक्योरिटी टेस्टिंग के लिए। आप जितने भी
लोग ज्वाइन करोगे या जितने भी लोग फ्यूचर
में पेन टेस्टिंग करोगे, सिक्योरिटी
टेस्टिंग करोगे किसी भी कंपनी के लिए तो
यह आपकी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है कि
जब आप सोशल इंजीनियरिंग परफॉर्म करोगे तो
आपके एथिक्स क्या है?
ठीक है? ताकि आप अपने आप को बचा सकें।
ताकि आप खुद को किसी मुसीबत में ना डालें
या आप खुद किसी मुसीबत में ना फंस जाए।
मेन काम यह होता है आप खुद मुसीबत में
नहीं पड़ना आपको। तो चलिए फिर हम बात करने
वाले हैं कि पहले हम देखेंगे कि की
कांसेप्ट हमारे क्या-क्या हैं। हम किन-किन
चीजों पर डिस्कस करने वाले हैं। सबसे पहले
हम डिस्कस हम डिस्कस करेंगे हमारे लीगल
रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज क्या है? उसके बाद सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग लीगली और एथिकली कैसे परफॉर्म
की जाती है?
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग में हम अपनी बाउंड्रीज
को कैसे एस्टैब्लिश कर सकते हैं?
और जो स्पूफिंग और रिकॉर्डिंग होती है
उसके लीगल कंसीडरेशंस क्या है? मतलब उसके
एथिक्स क्या है?
उसके बाद जो सर्विस कंसीडरेशन है या
टर्म्स ऑफ यूज़ टीओएस वह क्या होता है और
कैसे उसका ध्यान रखना है हमें।
एंड उसके बाद जब एक बार इंगेजमेंट हो जाती
है तो डी ब्रीफिंग क्या होती है? देन
मैनेजमेंट रिस्पांसिबिलिटी मैनेजमेंट की
क्या रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है? और लास्ट में हम
एक रियल वर्ल्ड केस स्टडी देखेंगे जिसमें
मैं आपको दिखाऊंगा कि
अगर आप एथिक्स यूज नहीं करते तो उसका
कितने बड़े भयंकर वाले सरकमस्ट्ससेस होते
हैं जो आपको आपने सोचे भी नहीं होंगे या
कभी आपने इमेजिन भी नहीं होगा। इतने भयंकर
सरकमस्ट्ससेस होते हैं। जस्ट आप अगर सोर्स
इंजीनियर को जस्ट फॉर फन पर्पज भी करते हो
तो ओके बिकॉज
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
क्योंकि बात ऐसी है हर कोई आपको सिखा देगा
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग कैसे काम करती है क्या
होती है कैसे करती है लेकिन कभी कोई भी
एथिक्स के बारे में बात नहीं करता ठीक है
इवन
आप पेड ट्रेनिंग में जाते हो तो एथिक्स
कोई कवर ही नहीं करता एथिक्स आपको खुद से
कवर करने पड़ते हैं एथिक्स आपको सीखने
पड़ते पढ़ते हैं। बट सारे एथिक्स तो हम
कवर नहीं कर सकते। लेकिन आप एक बिगिनियर
हो। आप बिल्कुल एक फील्ड में नए हो। आपको
नहीं पता सही गलत का। क्या चीज आपको करनी
चाहिए, क्या चीज आपको नहीं करनी चाहिए। तो
यही इस सेशन का मोटिव है। मेन गोल यही है
कि आप लोग जो चीज कर पा रहे हो, कर रहे हो
या जो चीज आप करने की सोच रहे हो तो आप
सोच समझ पाओ।
होप आप सोच समझ के वह चीज कर पाओ। मतलब आप
अपनी कॉमन सेंस, अपनी रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज या
जो आपकी एथिक्स हैं आप उनको समझ पाओ।
उसके बाद ही आप कोई डिसीजन लो और उसके बाद
ही आप वो अपना काम कंटिन्यू रख पाओ।
क्योंकि एंड ऑफ द डे क्या होगा?
यू आर द आप वह अकेले व्यक्ति होंगे उस जगह
पर।
जाने अनजाने में या तो एक्सपीरियंस के भाव
में या एक्सपीरियंस की कमी की वजह से या
नॉलेज की कमी की वजह से या किसी ने बताया
नहीं या आप सीख नहीं पाए या चीज आपसे वो
गलती हो गई क्योंकि गलती तब होती है जब
आपको चीज पता नहीं होती। तो जाने अनजाने
में आप किसी मुसीबत में ना फंस जाओ। मेन
मोटो यह है आज के सेशन का। ओके? मेन मोटो
यही है आज के सेशन का।
नेक्स्ट अभी बात करते हैं कि
जब भी हम कोई भी नेटवर्क पेन टेस्टिंग
करते हैं। फॉर एग्जांपल एक मिनट मैं अपना
पेन ले लेता हूं।
देखो जब भी हम नेटवर्क पेन टेस्टिंग करते
हैं या वेब एप्लीकेशन पेन टेस्टिंग करते
हैं तो हमारा इंपैक्ट कहां तक होता है?
किसी को पता है हमारा इंपैक्ट कहां तक
होता है? हमारे इंपैक्ट होता है या तो
किसी लैपटॉप तक होता है। किसी के लैपटॉप
तक हमारे इंपैक्ट होता है या फिर एक किसी
सर्वर तक हमारा इंपैक्ट होता है। कोई
सर्वर हो गया वहां तक हमारे इंपैक्ट होगा
या किसी वेब एप्लीकेशन तक हमारा इंपैक्ट
होगा। किसी एपीआई सर्वर तक हमारा इंपैक्ट
होगा। किसी फायर वाल या किसी इंटरप्राइज
नेटवर्क यहीं तक हमारा क्या होता है?
इंपैक्ट होता है। लेकिन जब बात आती है
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग की जब बात आती है आपकी
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग में। सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
में क्या होता है? सोशल इंजीनियरिंग में
आप मशीनों से डील नहीं करते। सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग में आप डील करते हो इंसानों
से या लोगों से और जहां पर लोग या इंसान
इंसान की बात करें इनवॉल्व हो जाते हैं तो
आपको ध्यान रखना है कि आपका एक छोटा सा भी
गलत स्टेप किसी को पर्सनली हर्ट कर सकता
है। ठीक है? किसी को भी पर्सनली हर्ट कर
सकता है। आई मीन कि अभी तक आपने नॉर्मल
पेन टेस्टिंग की होगी। वो चीजें इतनी हर्ट
नहीं करती। किसी की सोशल मोरालिटी मोरल की
बात करें या किसी
इमोशंस की बात करें या बुरा लगने वाली
बातें नहीं होती। बिकॉज़ आप सिस्टम के साथ
खेल रहे होते हैं हो। सिस्टम के साथ पेन
टेस्टिंग कर रहे होते हैं। लेकिन जब बात
आती है सोशल इंजिनिंग की। सोशल इंजिनिंग
में आप क्या करते हैं? सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
में मशीनें नहीं यूज होती है। सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग में यूज़ होती हैं सोशल
टैिक्स। यूज़ होते हैं इंसान। इंसान के
ट्रस्ट, उनके इमोशंस, वो सारी चीजें।
और अगर जहां पर इंसान इनवॉल्व हो गए और
जहां पर उनके इमोशंस आ गए तो समझ जाओ क्या
होगा? वहां पर पर्सनली हर्ट होने के भी
चांसेस बहुत ज्यादा हाई होते हैं। तो
इसलिए आपको एज एन एथिकल हैकर आपको कुछ
स्पेशल प्रिकॉशंस लेने होते हैं। आपको
क्या करने होते हैं? कुछ स्पेशल प्रिकॉशंस
लेने होते हैं। तो आपको कौन-कौन से
प्रिकॉशंस लेने होते हैं? मैं आपको बताता
हूं।
एथिकल हैकिंग इज नॉट जस्ट अबाउट फाइंडिंग
वनेबिलिटीज। इट इज आल्सो रिक्वायर
स्ट्रांग अंडरस्टैंडिंग ऑफ लीगल एंड एथिकल
रिससिबिलिटीज।
अब जो एथिकल हैकिंग है वह हमेशा
वनाबिलिटीज फाइंडिंग के लिए ही नहीं होती।
एथिकल हैकिंग में आपको
आपकी जो लीगल रिससिबिलिटीज होती है या जो
आपके एथिकल रिससिबिलिटीज होती है। लीगल का
मतलब कानून व्यवस्था मतलब आपके जो लॉज़
हैं, आपके जो लॉ है या जो एथिकल
रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज है उनकी भी आपको
स्ट्रांग अंडरस्टैंडिंग होनी चाहिए। बस
आपको इतना नहीं पता होना चाहिए कि मुझे
वनेरबिलिटी फाइंड आउट करनी आती है। मुझे
बग बाउंट करनी आती है। मैं बग बाउंट कर
लूंगा। मैं बग फाइंड आउट कर लूंगा और
रिपोर्ट कर दूंगा। नहीं एथिकल हैकिंग या
पेन टेस्टिंग में ऐसा नहीं होता। आपको हर
एक चीज का पता होना चाहिए। बेसिकली आपको
उन रिस्पांसिबिलिटी के बारे में पता होना
चाहिए। सही और गलत लीगल इललीगल एथिक्स इन
सब के बारे में आपको पता होना चाहिए।
बेसिकली आपकी जो लीगल रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज
हैं आप उससे पूरी तरह से अवेयर होने
चाहिए। अब लीगल रिस्पोंसिबिलिटीज क्या
होती है? बिफोर कंडक्टिंग एनी सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग इंगेजमेंट ए पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टर्स शुड अंडरस्टैंड द साइबर
सिक्योरिटी एंड प्राइवेसी लॉ एप्लीकेबल इन
देयर ओन कंट्री जब कोई भी सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग इंगेजमेंट से पहले एज ए
पेंटेस्टस आपको पता होना चाहिए आपकी जो
कंट्री है उसके साइबर लॉ कौन-कौन से हैं
या साइबर सिक्योरिटी लॉज़ कौन से हैं या
प्राइवेसी लॉज़ कौन-कौन से एप्लीकेबल होते
हैं आप पर इनकी आपको नॉलेज होनी चाहिए।
लॉज़ की नॉलेज आपको होनी चाहिए। इट इज
इक्वलीेंट टू स्टडी द लॉज़ गवर्न सॉरी मैं
थोड़ा प्रोनाउंस नहीं कर पा रहा इसका।
गवर्निंग द क्लाइंट्स कंट्री और रीजन।
ओके? क्लाइंट्स कंट्री और रीजन एज लीगल
रिक्वायरमेंट वेरी सिग्निफिकेंटली अक्रॉस
जुरिडिस्टिकेशन।
मतलब
इसका मतलब क्या है? कि आपको अपनी कंट्री
के अलावा जिस भी कंपनी के लिए आप काम कर
रहे हो वह कंपनी जिस कंट्री में से ऑपरेट
कर रही है जिस रीजन से ऑपरेट कर रही है
उसका भी कुछ ना कुछ जुरिस्ट्रिक्शन
होता है। सॉरी मैं बोल नहीं पा रहा पता
नहीं आई डोंट नो कि आज क्या हो रहा है।
जुरिडिक्शन होता है। सॉरी उसका इसको वो
करो आप थोड़ा सा अवॉइड करो पता नहीं।
उनका जो एरियाज मतलब कि जिस भी रीजन या
जिस भी कंट्री से वो ऑपरेट करती है करती
है वो कंपनी आपको वहां के लॉ उनके बारे
में आपको पता होना चाहिए। वहां के जो
साइबर लॉ है वहां के जो प्राइवेसी लॉज़ हैं
उनके बारे में भी आपको पता होना चाहिए।
एक्टिविटीज दैट आर परफेक्टली लीगल इन वन
कंट्री मे रिक्वायर एडिशनल ऑथराइजेशन और
मे इवन बी प्रोवाइडेड इन अनदर। अब हो सकता
है कि जो एक्टिविटीज आपकी कंट्री में या
किसी एक कंट्री में परफेक्टली लीगल है वह
जरूरी नहीं है कि दूसरी कंट्री में भी
परफेक्टली लीगल हो। हो सकता है उनके लिए
आपको कोई एडिशनल ऑथराइजेशन चाहिए होता है।
एडिशनल अथॉरिटी चाहिए होती है या हो सकता
है
वो स्ट्रिक्टली प्रोहबिटेड हो। मतलब
वो एक्टिविटी आप परफॉर्म ही नहीं कर सकते
उस कंट्री में। मतलब यह है एक तो आपको
अपनी कंट्री के लॉ के बारे में पता होना
चाहिए। कौन से? स्पेशली साइबर सिक्योरिटी
से रिलेटेड। दूसरा जो कंपनी जहां से ऑपरेट
कर रही है कंपनी के क्या लॉ है या जो जिस
रीजन में ऑपरेट कर रही है उस रीजन के लॉ
क्या है या फिर थर्ड वन थर्ड वन नहीं या
फिर उसका मतलब क्या है कि आपकी जो कंट्री
के लॉ जरूरी नहीं है कि जहां से वह कंपनी
ऑपरेट कर रही है अभी बात हो रही है अदर
कंट्री की या अदर रीजन कि आपके जो लीगलिटी
है उस कंट्री में वो चीजें लीगल ना हो।
ओके नेक्स्ट
इग्नोरेंस ऑफ लॉ इज नेवर कंसीडर्ड एज अ
वैलिड डिफेंस ड्यूरिंग ए सिक्योरिटी
असेसमेंट।
अभी आप सिक्योरिटी असेसमेंट कर रहे हो। आप
पेन टेस्टिंग कर रहे हो। अब आपको लॉ नहीं
पता या आपने लॉ को इग्नोर कर दिया और आप
पे कोई लीगल एक्शन हो गया तो फिर आप यह
बहाना नहीं दे सकते कि मुझे पता नहीं था।
मुझे इसके बारे में नहीं पता था। किसी ने
मुझे बताया नहीं। आप यह बहाना नहीं दे
सकते किसी भी असेसमेंट के दौरान। मतलब
आपको इन सब की अच्छे से नॉलेज होनी चाहिए।
आपका यह बहाना नहीं चलेगा अपने आप को
बचाने के लिए कि मुझे किसी ने पढ़ाया
नहीं, मुझे किसी ने सिखाया नहीं। मुझे
नहीं पता था। यह सब चीजें नहीं चलेंगी।
ड्यूरिंग ए सिक्योरिटी असेसमेंट। ओके? ए
प्रोफेशनल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स ऑलवेज
परफॉर्म लीगल ड्यू टू डलगेंस बिफोर
इंटक्टिंग विद एंप्लॉय सिस्टम्स एंड
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन डाटा। मतलब यह है कि जब भी
कोई प्रोफेशनल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर पेन
टेस्टिंग करता है तो यह माना जाता है कि
वह सारे काम लीगल तरीके से करेगा। चाहे वह
एंप्लई से इंटैक्ट करना हो, सिस्टम से
इंटैक्ट करना हो, चाहे ऑर्गेनाइजेशन डाटा
के साथ डील करना है। माना यही जाता है कि
वह लीगली करेगा। एक एथिकल वे में करेगा।
बिकॉज़ उस तरीके से उसको ट्रेन किया जाता
है। उस तरीके से उसको ट्रेनिंग दी जाती
है। उस तरीके से उसको सिखाया जाता है। सो
टेक्निकल ऑथराइजेशन अलोन इज नॉट एनफ। लीगल
कंप्लायंस इज इक्वलीेंट। इसलिए कहने का
मतलब यह है कि जो टेक्निकल ऑथराइजेशन है
वह एनफ नहीं है। लीगल कंप्लायंस भी इक्वली
इंपॉर्टेंट होते हैं। टेक्निकल ऑथराइजेशन
के अलावा आपको लीगल कंप्लायंस की भी पूरी
तरह से समझ होनी चाहिए। ऐसा नहीं है कि
मुझे नहीं पता था। यह बहाना नहीं चलेगा।
ओके। नेक्स्ट
अभी हम बात करते हैं कि
पब्लिक इंफॉर्मेशन स्टिल रिक्वायर
रिस्पांसिबल हैंडलिंग के बारे में। मतलब
यह है कि जब भी आप सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
असेसमेंट परफॉर्म करते हैं, सबको पता है
उसमें हम किसका यूज़ करते हैं? ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस का। और ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस
में हम क्या करते हैं? पब्लिकली अवेलेबल
सोर्सेस से इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट करते हैं।
एंड ऑलदो कलेक्टिंग पब्लिक पब्लिक
इंफॉर्मेशन इज जनरली परमिसिबल। हालांकि जो
पब्लिक इंफॉर्मेशन को कलेक्ट करना जनरली
परमिसबल्स होता है। इस पर कोई लॉ नहीं है
कि आप पब्लिकली इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट नहीं कर
सकते। ऐसा नहीं है। द रिस्पांसिबिलिटी ऑफ
प्रोटेक्टिंग दैट इंफॉर्मेशन रिमेंस विद द
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स। लेकिन अगर आपने ओपन
सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस से
पब्लिकली अवेलेबल इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट कर ली
है तो फिर कलेक्ट करने के बाद उस
इंफॉर्मेशन को प्रोटेक्ट करना ही
प्रोटेक्ट करना एक पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स की
जिम्मेदारी बन जाती है। ठीक है? उसको
प्रोटेक्ट करने की जिम्मेदारी फिर बन जाती
है पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर की। वही इंफॉर्मेशन
जब तक पब्लिक है, है कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं।
वह इंफॉर्मेशन आपने कलेक्ट की है। आपने
उसको अपने पास रखा है अपने मतलब के लिए तो
वो इंफॉर्मेशन फिर आपको अपने पास रखनी है।
उसकी जो टेक केयर है वह आपकी
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी होगी। फिर डाटा
प्रोटेक्शन रेगुलेशन सच एज जनरल डाटा
प्रोटेक्शन जीडीपीआर रिक्वायर
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस एंड सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल
टू हैंडल पर्सनल इंफॉर्मेशन सिक्योरली एक
जीडीपीआर के बारे में सुना होगा यह एक
एक्ट है इसके अकॉर्डिंग जो पर्सनल
इंफॉर्मेशन है उसकी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी एक
सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल्स और उस
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस की है। उसको हैंडल करने की
रिसोंसिबिलिटी किसकी है? उस
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस और उसके जो सिक्योरिटी
प्रोफेशनल्स हैं उनकी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है।
इंप्रोपर स्टोरेज अननेसेसरी शेयरिंग और
एक्सीडेंटल डिस्क्लोज़र ऑफ कलेक्टेड
इंफॉर्मेशन मे रिजल्ट इन लीगल फाइनेंशियल
एंड रेपुटेशनल क्सक्वेंसेस। इसका मतलब
क्या है कि आपने इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट कर ली।
उसके बाद अगर आपने उसको सही से स्टोर नहीं
किया या अननेसेसरी किसी के साथ उसको शेयर
कर दिया या जाने या अनजाने में वह चोरी हो
गई डिस्क्लोज हो गई आपके द्वारा कलेक्ट की
हुई इंफॉर्मेशन तो फिर आपके ऊपर लीगल
एकशंस हो सकते हैं। आपके ऊपर कानूनी
कारवाई हो सकती है। आपको हो सकता है कि
पुलिस के चक्कर काटने पड़ जाए या फिर आपको
फाइनेंशियल लॉस फाइन मतलब कि आपके ऊपर
फाइनेंशियल फाइन लग जाए या फिर जो
रेपुटेशन है आपकी आप एक पेन टेस्ट हो।
आपकी रेपुटेशन डैमेज हो जाए। आपकी जॉब चली
जाए या फिर आपके से कोई पेन टेस्टिंग ना
करवाए। यह सारे सरकमस्ट्ससेस हो जाते हैं।
नेक्स्ट एथिकल हैकर्स शुड कलेक्ट ओनली द
इंफॉर्मेशन रिक्वायर्ड फॉर असेसमेंट एंड
सिक्योरली डिस्पोज ऑफ इट आफ्टर द
इंगेजमेंट इज कंप्लीटेड। कहने का मतलब
क्या है? कि जो भी एथिकल हैकर्स है उसको
वही इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट करनी चाहिए जो
असेसमेंट के लिए जरूरी है और उसके बाद
इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट करने के बाद उसको
डिस्पोज करना भी सिक्योरली डिस्पोज करना
भी उसी की जिम्मेदारी है इंगेजमेंट
कंप्लीट होने के बाद ऐसा नहीं है कि आपने
इंगेजमेंट कंप्लीट हो गए हैं। आपने पेन
टेस्टिंग कंप्लीट कर ली है। उसके बाद भी
वह इंफॉर्मेशन आप अपने पास ले घूम रहे हो
तो इट इज इललीगल। वो लीगल नहीं है।
रिस्पांसिबल डाटा हैंडलिंग डेमोंस्ट्रेट
प्रोफेशनलिज्म एंड बिल्ड ट्रस्ट बिटवीन द
टेस्टर्स एंड क्लाइंट। जब आप इस तरीके से
इतने रिस्पांसिबिलिटी के साथ डाटा को
हैंडल करते हो तो यह आपको डेमोंस्ट्रेट
करता है। यह किसी को दर्शाता है कि आप एक
प्रोफेशनल सिक्योरिटी टेस्टर्स हो और
जिससे क्या होता है? एक टेस्टर्स और
क्लाइंट के बीच में ट्रस्ट बिल्ड होता है।
विश्वास बिल्ड होता है। तो बेस्ट
प्रैक्टिस क्या होती है? कलेक्ट ओनली
व्हाट इज नेसेसरी। प्रोटेक्ट एवरीथिंग यू
कलेक्ट एंड नेवर रिटेन इनेशन लगर देन
रिक्वायर्ड। इसलिए सबसे बेस्ट प्रैक्टिस
क्या है कि जो जरूरी है वही इंफॉर्मेशन
कलेक्ट करो और जो इंफॉर्मेशन आपने कलेक्ट
की है उसको प्रोटेक्ट करो। वह आपकी
जिम्मेदारी है। उसके बाद उसकी जरूरत खत्म
होने पर उसको डिस्पोज करना भी आप ही की
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है।
ओके।
नेक्स्ट
नेक्स्ट टॉपिक है हमारा
लेट अस ब्रेक डाउन हाउ टू डू सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग लीगली एंड एथिकली। चलो अब बात
करते हैं कि जो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग है उसको
एथिकली और लीगली कैसे परफॉर्म किया जाता
है? इसलिए अब आ गई हमारी बात किसकी?
एक्चुअल इंगेजमेंट की। जब आप किसी भी
कंपनी के लिए क्या करते हो? जब आप किसी भी
कंपनी के लिए सोशल इंजीनियरिंग परफॉर्म
करते हो तो
तो
आपको क्या करना है? तो यू हैव टू बी हाईली
सेंसिटिव कि आपके जो एक्शंस है सामने वाले
टारगेट को कैसा फील होंगे। मतलब आपको इसके
बारे में बिल्कुल सोचना पड़ेगा कि आप जो
भी एक्शन लेने वाले हो, जो भी आप अटैक
परफॉर्म करने वाले हो, उसके सरकमस्ट्ससेस
क्या होंगे? सामने वाले इंसान के ऊपर
सामने वाले लोगों के ऊपर ठीक है वही मैं
आपको बता रहा हूं। ठीक है? यह मोराल
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी की बात आ गई। तो हमारा
गोल क्या है? पहली बात मुझे यह बताओ सब
लोग कि हमारा गोल क्या है? गोल क्या है
हमारा?
यहां पर 11 स्टूडेंट है। इतने दिन से सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग का बेसिक पढ़ रहे हैं हम।
हमारा गोल क्या है?
व्हाट इज आवर गोल?
निखिल बताओ निखिल जगत गुरु जी हमारा गोल
क्या है? हमारा एम क्या है?
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग करने का हमारा ऐ क्या
है?
चैट में टाइप करो
हमारा ऐ या सोशल इंजीनियरिंग तो हम सीख
रहे हैं। हम यहां पर बात करें एथिक्स की
तो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग करने करते वक्त हमारा
एम क्या है?
हमारा अगर आपको सोशल इंजीनियरिंग नो नो नो
नो नो नो नो फॉर एग्जांपल्स आपको यह बोला
गया है कि आपको इस ऑर्गेनाइजेशन की सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग करनी है। आपको सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग अटैक परफॉर्म करना है। तो आप
अभी आप सोचो कि आप एक पेंटेस्ट की तरह
सोचो।
ठीक है? एक पेंटेस्ट की तरह सोचो। आपकी
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी क्या है कि भाई आपको सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग करने के लिए जिम्मेदार क्यों
बोला गया? क्यों कोई ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस आपसे
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग करवा रही है? और आप
क्यों कर रहे हो? किस पर्पज से आप कर रहे
हो?
ओके चलो
1520 गुड
अच्छा है आपका जवाब नियरली है।
फाइंडिंग द वीकनेसेस टू गेट सेंसिटिव।
किसकी वीकनेसेस?
नो नो नो नो नो थोड़े-थोड़े
थोड़ा सा ब्रॉड माइंड से सोचो। सोचो सोचो
थोड़ा सा सोचो कि क्यों? क्यों? जल्दी देखो
आंसर जल्दी करो। इंटरेक्टिव सेशन बना रहा
हूं। तो आंसर बहुत जल्दी चाहिए आप लोगों
से।
किसी भी काम को निकलवाने के लिए करते हैं।
नो निखिल अबाउट ह टू फाइंड वनरिटी ऑफ़ एन
ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस। प्रणय वेरी गुड बेटा। वेरी
वेरी गुड। एक्सीलेंट आपने अच्छा जवाब दिया
है। उसके अलावा एक और थे हमारे 1530। यू
आर आल्सो वेरी गुड। और कोई बताओ।
देखो मैं ही बता दूंगा तो फिर क्या फायदा
हुआ? मैं तो बता ही दूंगा।
बताओ
नहीं पता तो मना कर दो। गलत है तो बताओ।
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं। मैं हूं ना डिसीड
करने।
देखिए मैं बता देता हूं। हमारा गोल है यह
देखना कि कंपनी वनेबल है क्योंकि एंप्लाइज
के पास प्रॉपर ट्रेनिंग नहीं है।
ठीक है? हमारा गोल है कि जो कंपनी है
कंपनी में वनेबिलिटीज है। बट
वो वनेबिलिटीज का कारण क्या है? एमंप्लई
नहीं एंप्लई के पास उनको हैंडल करने की
प्रॉपर ट्रेनिंग नहीं है। समझ में आ गया?
हमारा गोल है यह प्रूव करना या यह बताना
कि भैया आपकी जो कंपनी है उसमें कमियां
है। लूप होल्स हैं। यह यह लूप होल है। बट
किसकी वजह से? एंप्लॉय की वजह से नहीं।
आपकी ट्रेनिंग की कमी की वजह से। आपकी
सिक्योरिटी अवेयरनेस की कमी की वजह से।
आपकी आपको ट्रेनिंग आपकी जो ट्रेनिंग है
या तो उसको इंप्रूवमेंट की जरूरत है या
फिर आप सही से ट्रेन नहीं कर रहे। ठीक है?
या आपकी जो प्रोसेस है रिपोर्टिंग प्रोसेस
है कि अगर कोई
आपको थ्रेट दिखे तो उसका या तो प्रोसेस
वीक है या उससे फिर आपके एंप्लाइज सही तरह
से अवेयर नहीं है। यह मतलब मेरे कहने का
मतलब क्या है कि हमारा गोल यह नहीं है कि
किसी भी एक एंप्लॉय को विक्टिम या विलेन
बनाकर सबके सामने एक्सपोज कर दें। यह
हमारा गोल नहीं है। हमारा गोल बिल्कुल भी
नहीं है कि किसी एक बंदे को हम पकड़े और
उसको क्या किया? सबके सामने एक्सपोज कर
दिया और सबके सामने उसको क्या कर दिया?
बकरा बना दिया। ठीक है? सबके सामने देख कि
हां दैट इज द पर्सन जिसकी वजह से आपकी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट हुई। यह
हमारा गोल एंड गोल कभी भी नहीं है। एवरीवन
क्लियर हमारा गोल क्या है?
सबको पता चल गया कि अगर कोई आपसे पूछे फॉर
एग्जांपल्स
कि हमारा जो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग करने का मेन
गोल क्या है? व्हाट इज द मेन गोल ऑफ सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग
टू अगेंस्ट एन ऑर्गेनाइजेशन।
ठीक है? हमारा गोल है कि कंपनी में
वनेबिलिटी ढूंढना, कंपनी के अंदर वनेबल
एंड पॉइंट्स या वनेबल पॉइंट्स को फाइंड
आउट करना और यह यह बताना कि कहां कमी थी।
कमी एंप्लई की नहीं कमी कि उनकी या तो
अवेयरनेस की कमी थी। ट्रेनिंग ढंग से नहीं
कर रहे थे या फिर उनकी ट्रेनिंग का जो
मॉड्यूल है वह कमजोर है। और ज्यादा
ट्रेनिंग की रिक्वायरमेंट है या उनकी
प्रोसेस में कमी है या मतलब ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
अपना काम सही से नहीं कर रही। समझ में आया
सबको यह बात?
सबको यह बात समझ में आई? लेकिन आपके मन
में एक सवाल घूम रहा होगा। एक सवाल होगा
कि सर ठीक है आप सही बात बोल रहे हो कि
अवेयरनेस की कमी के वजह से
अह
एम्प्लाइज ने गलती कर दी। बट सर हम यह
कैसे रिपोर्ट में लिखेंगे? ठीक है? यह
कैसे रिपोर्ट में लिखेंगे कि इतने
अटेम्प्ट हुए इतनी सक्सेस रेट है। ये है
देखो यहां कहीं पर किसी को हाईलाइट किया
या पर्टिकुलर एंप्लॉय को नहीं हाईलाइट
किया गया। तो इस तरह की रिपोर्ट हम कैसे
लिखेंगे सर? कैसे इसका सशन क्या है? आपने
तो बोल दिया कि एमंप्लई तो हमें मिलेंगे
ही। बकरे तो हमें मिलेंगे ही। बट सर सशन
क्या है? बताओ यह रिपोर्ट कैसे लिख सकते
हैं हम? क्या करके लिख सकते हैं हम ये
रिपोर्ट?
उसके लिए आपको मेंटेन करनी है। एनोनिटी
क्या मेंटेन करना है आपको? एनोनिटी लिखने
की जरूरत है क्या?
आपको क्या मेंटेन करना है? एनोनिमिटी
मेंटेन करनी है। मतलब
जब भी आप अपनी रिपोर्ट लिखोगे, रिपोर्ट
में कभी भी यह मत लिखना कि अकाउंटिंग
डिपार्टमेंट के जॉन स्मिथ या जो फाइनेंस
डिपार्टमेंट का जो जॉन स्मिथ है, ठीक है?
उसने फिशिंग लिंक पर क्लिक किया और या
उसने क्रेडेंशियल्स एंटर किए।
इस तरीके की रिपोर्ट आपको नहीं बनानी है
कि जॉन स्मिथ था फाइनेंस डिपार्टमेंट से
फाइनल फाइनेंस एनालिस्ट यह उसकी ईमेल आईडी
है। उसने क्या किया? 6 मई 2024 को 10:24
पर सुबह एक लिंक पर क्लिक किया और अपने
क्रेडेंशियल्स एंटर करने की कोशिश की।
आपको रिपोर्ट में यह नहीं लिखना है। इस
चीज का आपको ध्यान में रखना है। आपको
रिपोर्ट में यह नहीं लिखना है। आपको
रिपोर्ट में क्या लिखना है? इसके बजाय आप
क्या लिख सकते हो? आप लिख सकते हो कि
अकाउंटिंग या फाइनेंस डिपार्टमेंट के कुछ
एंप्लई ने फेसिंग लिंक पर क्लिक किया। कुछ
ने क्रेडेंशियल एंटर करने की कोशिश की।
मतलब यह रही डेमोंस्ट्रेशन एन एंप्लॉय
फ्रॉम द फाइनेंस डिपार्टमेंट इंटरेक्टेड
विद द फेसिंग सिमुलेशन क्या किसी का नाम
हाईलाइट हुआ नहीं हुआ 250 एंप्लॉय थे 28
ने इंटरेक्ट किया तीन इफेक्ट हुए मतलब
रिस्क लेवल क्या है मॉडरेट है मतलब यहां
पर क्या मेंटेन किया गया एनोनिमिटी मेंटेन
की गई किसी को पर्सनली हाईलाइट नहीं किया
गया बट
बट
यहां पर भी एक लॉजिक है। लॉजिक क्या है कि
यहां पर भी आपको एक बात का ध्यान रखना है।
किस चीज का?
साइज ऑफ कंपनी।
अभी जिस रिपोर्टिंग का मैंने जिक्र किया
था। यहां पर भी आपको ध्यान रखना है कि
कंपनी का साइज क्या है? पहली बात देखो यह
रिपोर्टिंग करनी नहीं है। इस टाइप की
रिपोर्टिंग करनी है। तो यह रिपोर्टिंग
लिखते वक्त भी आपको क्या करना है? ध्यान
रखना है साइज ऑफ ऑफिस। आगे देखो अगर कंपनी
का साइज क्या है? छोटा है और आपने वो
रिपोर्ट लिखी तो उसमें फॉर एग्जांपल लिया
फाइनेंस डिपार्टमेंट के कुछ लोगों ने या
एक लोग एक फाइनेंस डिपार्टमेंट से किसी एक
ने या दो ने क्या किया? लिंक क्लिक किया
और ट्रेडेंशियल एंटर किए। फॉर एग्जांपल एक
छोटी कंपनी है। फाइनेंस डिपार्टमेंट लोग
ही तीन है।
तो भाई कोई भी आईडिया लगा लेगा तीन लोग
हैं। तो हो सकता है इन तीन में इसने किया
होगा।
सॉरी ओके ओके ये गलत मैंने लिख दिया। तो
ऐसे नहीं लिखना है। फिर इसमें ऐसे भी नहीं
लिखना है। इसमें आप कैसे लिख सकते हो?
इसमें लिख सकते हो कि मैं एक मिनट इसको रब
कर देता हूं।
ओके ओके इसमें आप किस तरीके से लिखोगे अगर
छोटी कंपनी है तो मतलब आपको रिपोर्टिंग
सोच समझ कर लिखनी है कि मेरी रिपोर्ट क्या
होनी चाहिए क्योंकि हमेशा रिपोर्ट में ही
टाइम लगता है कि एक या एक से ज्यादा
एंप्लई फाइनेंस डिपार्टमेंट से उन्होंने
फिशिंग लिंक के साथ इंटरेक्ट किया। अब
इसमें क्या है कि वह आईडिया नहीं लगा
पाएंगे। एक या एक से ज्यादा तीन में भी वो
आईडिया नहीं लगा पाएंगे। लेकिन आप हाईलाइट
करते कि फाइनेंस डिपार्टमेंट से एक एंप्लई
ने वह किया है तो वह आईडिया लगा लेते। ठीक
है? तो इस तरीके से आपको क्या करनी है?
रिपोर्टिंग करनी है। या फिर आपको जो
रिपोर्ट लिखोगे आप अगर कंपनी बड़ी है तो
कोई फर्क ही नहीं पड़ता। फॉर एग्जांपल
उसमें 1200 एंप्लॉय फाइनेंस के हैं। ठीक
है? 312 ईमेल सेंड की गई। 87 उस पे क्लिक
कर दिया। 28% कंट्रक्शन रेट हो गई। रिस्क
मीडियम लेवल है। अब इसमें आप दो एंप्लॉय
लिखो, 87 लिखो। किसी को फर्क पड़ेगा नहीं
पड़ेगा क्योंकि 1200 में से 80 एम्प्ल 80
या 100 एंप्लई को भी अलग से हाईलाइट करना
उनके बारे में सोचना किसी के बस की बात
नहीं है भाई इतना किसी के पास टाइम नहीं
है तो आप जो रिपोर्टिंग लिखोगे आप जो
रिपोर्ट लिखते हो आपकी रिपोर्ट बहुत मैटर
करती है जब भी आप रिपोर्ट लिखते हो तो
रिपोर्ट सोच समझ के लिखना सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग की कि कई चीजें ध्यान रखनी
है। एक तो आपको किसी भी एंप्लई को
डायरेक्ट टारगेट नहीं करना है। भाई किसी
भी एंप्लई को बिल्कुल भी डायरेक्ट टारगेट
नहीं करना है। दूसरा आपकी जो रिपोर्ट
रहेगी उसमें एन एनोनिमिटी मेंटेन करनी है।
एनोनिमिटी मेंटेन करते वक्त आपको दो चीज़
और ध्यान रखनी है कि कंपनी का साइज क्या
है क्या है या जो डिपार्टमेंट आपने टारगेट
किया है उसका साइज क्या है? क्योंकि कंपनी
में बहुत सारे छोटे-छोटे डिपार्टमेंट होते
हैं। फाइनेंस डिपार्टमेंट होगा,
मार्केटिंग डिपार्टमेंट होगा, एचआर
डिपार्टमेंट हो गया, नॉर्मल काम करने के
एंप्लॉय हो गए, आईटीआई डिपार्टमेंट होगा
या और अदर डिपार्टमेंट्स होंगे, छोटे-छोटे
जो डेवलपमेंट होगा, डेवलपमेंट में मल्टीपल
डिपार्टमेंट हो गए। तो वो साइज आपको ध्यान
रखना है कि ओके मुझे रिपोर्ट कैसे लिखनी
है ताकि मेरा जो एंप्लॉय है वो एंप्लॉय के
ऊपर कोई भी प्रॉब्लम नहीं आनी चाहिए।
बिकॉज़ अल्टीमेटली वह भी आपकी तरह ही जॉब
करने वाला ही एक व्यक्ति है जो डेली बेसिस
पर अपना काम कर रहा होता है। ठीक है? तो
यह चीज आपको ध्यान में आ गई। समझ में आ गई
आपको?
यहां तक सबको क्लियर है?
पता चल रहा है ये चीजें कोई बताता है इन
सब चीजों के बारे में। किसी को पता था
पहले
यहां पर बताओ। किसी को पता था इन सब चीजों
के बारे में
चंदन पता था आपको प्रणय पता था
क्योंकि यह वो चीजें हैं जो हम कभी भी
अपनी क्लासेस में डिस्कस नहीं करते हैं हम
अपने आप को
ट्रेनिंग के तुरंत बाद समझने लग जाते हैं।
मुझे सब कुछ पता है और हम ब्लाइंडली ट्राई
करते हैं। लेकिन हमें उनके लीगल
कंसिस्टेंसी के बारे में बिल्कुल कभी नहीं
पता होता। जिसकी वजह से बहुत सारे
जो बिगिनर्स होते हैं वो इनिशियल फेज में
ही फंसते चले जाते हैं ट्रैप्स में। बिकॉज़
रियल नॉलेज बहुत कम मिलती है बहुत लोगों
को। ठीक है? तो नेक्स्ट अभी हम बात करते
हैं कि मैंने आपको पहले बताया था कि सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग हम किसकी तरह करेंगे
कि हम एक एथिकल वे में लेकिन जो बैड गाय
है जो आपका जो अटैकर्स हैकर
है ठीक है उसके सारे स्टेप्स को कॉपी
करेंगे लेकिन एक और चीज है आप उसको
ब्लाइंडली कॉपी नहीं करना है ठीक है
ब्लाइंडली ली कॉपी नहीं करना है।
ब्लाइंडली अलाउड नहीं है। ब्लाइंडली मतलब
कि जैसे एक रियल अटैकर क्या-क्या करता है?
सब कुछ करता है। डीडीओस करता है, डोस करता
है, डॉक्सिंग करता है, रसमवेयर अटैक
परफॉर्म करता है, अनअ ऑथराइज एक्शन करता
है, डेटा थप्ट करता है, डिस्ट्रक्टिव
एक्शंस करता है। बहुत सारी चीज़ एक्शन
परफॉर्म करता है। बट हम नहीं करेंगे ऐसे।
हम उसके स्टेप्स कॉपी जरूर करेंगे। उसके
स्टेप्स को कॉपी भी करना है क्योंकि उसकी
टेिक्स को उसकी टेक्निक को समझने के लिए
बट हमें क्या करना है उनके सारे स्टेप्स
को आंख बंद करके नहीं कॉपी करने वाले जो
भी कुछ करेंगे हम एथिकल वे में करेंगे
पूरे ऑथराइजेशन के साथ करेंगे अपने दायरे
में रह के करेंगे अपने स्कोप के अंदर
करेंगे ठीक है बिल्कुल प्रोफेशनल वे में
करेंगे ठीक है एंप्लई की प्राइवेसी ध्यान
में रखते हुए करेंगे और जो हमारी
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है उसको ध्यान में रखते
करते हुए करेंगे। करेंगे जरूर बट इतनी
सारी चीजों को सोचते समझते हुए करेंगे
क्योंकि अल्टीमेटली वी आर एथिकल हैकर नॉट
ए बैड एक्टर।
तो
चलिए यह समझ में आ गया। एक सवाल पूछा है
जेडी कोडर ने सर अगर एक या दो ही
बंदे होंगे तो उस डिपार्टमेंट में तो
डिपार्टमेंट का नाम ही हाईलाइट नहीं करना
फॉर एग्जांपल एक छोटी सी कंपनी है 15
लोगों की अकाउंट का एक है एचआर का एक है
ऐसे छोटे-छोटे डिपार्टमेंट आके 15 ही बंदे
हैं तो रिपोर्ट में क्या लिखोगे फाइनेंस
अकाउंट डिपार्टमेंट नो उसमें रिपोर्ट में
लिखोगे कि कुछ एक या एक से ज्यादा लोगों
ने कंपनी के एक या एक से ज्यादा लोगों ने
क्या किया है? क्लिक किया है। ट्राई किया
है। बस इसमें कोई शक ही नहीं है।
अंडरस्टुड?
आपको सोचना है आपकी रिपोर्ट के हिसाब से
आपको क्या लिखना है। अंडरस्टुड?
अंडरस्टुड?
समझ में आया?
चलिए अभी हम बात करते हैं एस्टब्लिशिंग
बाउंड्रीज इन सोशल इंजीनियरिंग।
मतलब बाउंड्रीज कैसे सेट करते हैं?
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग में हमें अपनी बाउंड्रीज
को कैसे सेट करना है? मतलब अपनी जो
लिमिट्स हैं उनको कैसे सेट करना है कि
मुझे यहां तक लिमिट रखनी है अपनी। ठीक है?
सबसे पहले बात करते हैं हम कि फॉर
एग्जांपल आप एक सोशल इंजीनियरिंग परफॉर्म
कर रहे हो। ठीक है? आप एक सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग परफॉर्म कर रहे हो और आप क्या
कर रहे हो? विशिंग टेक्निक परफॉर्म कर रहे
हो। कौन सी? विशिंग।
आप परफॉर्म कर रहे हो विशिंग। विशिंग सबको
पता है क्या होता है? कॉल कॉल पे आप क्या
करते हो? किसी को मैनपुलेट करने की कोशिश
करते हो। अब आप किसी आपने बोला कि हे
एलेक्स मैं आईटी डिपार्टमेंट से बात कर
रहा हूं और मुझे कोई डिटेल्स वेरीफाई करनी
है।
अगर
चाहे विशिंग हो
ईमेल हो कोई भी तरीका हो अगर एंप्लई ने
आपसे बात करने से मना कर दिया या फिर आपका
फोन कट कर दिया।
ध्यान से सुनो। अगर एंप्लई ने आपसे बात
करने से मना कर दिया या फिर आपका फोन कॉल
कट कर दिया तो आपको क्या करना है? वहीं पर
स्टॉप
मतलब उस एंप्लई के लिए आपको क्या करना है?
वहीं पर स्टॉप हो जाना है। उस एंप्लॉय पर
आपको क्या नहीं करना? दोबारा
दोबारा उस पे ट्राई नहीं करना। ठीक है? उस
पे दोबारा उसको फोर्स नहीं करना है। ठीक
है? मतलब जो एंप्लई है उसका जो डिसीजंस था
उसको क्या करना है आपको रिस्पेक्ट करना
है। उसके डिसीजन की आपको क्या करनी है?
रिस्पेक्ट करनी है। तो रिस्पेक्ट द
एंप्लाइजस डिसीजन इमीडिएटली।
स्टॉप द कन्वर्जेशन राइट अवे। सेम टाइप
क्या करना है? आपको जो कन्वर्जेशन बातचीत
शुरू हो रही थी, एंप्लई ने मना कर दिया।
कोई भी बहाना दिया हो या फोन कट कर दिया
तो आपको बार-बार उसके साथ उसको कॉल नहीं
करना है दोबारा से। उसके साथ आर्गुममेंट
नहीं करना है या उसके साथ और कोई तरीका
अपनाना नहीं है इंफॉर्मेशन निकलवाने के
लिए। मतलब उसको हरास नहीं करना है। परेशान
नहीं करना है। समझ में आ गई? इंटरेक्शन
वहीं पर कंप्लीट कर दो उस पर्टिकुलर
एंप्लई के साथ। यह नहीं बोला अपनी आप
सोर्स इंजीनियरिंग बंद कर दो। उस
पर्टिकुलर एंप्लई को लिस्ट से हटा दो।
क्रॉस मार्क कर दो। ओके? सेफ। ठीक है?
उसके साथ अनप्रोफेशनल बिहेवियर नहीं करना
है। बेसिकली आपको क्या करना है? आपका जो
प्रोफेशनलिज्म है उसको मेंटेन करना है।
आपको खुद की भी रिस्पेक्ट मेंटेन करनी है।
सामने जो एंप्लॉय है उसको भी रिस्पेक्ट
देनी है। और साथ में आपकी जो इंटीग्रिटी
है उसको भी मेंटेन करना है। ठीक है? आपकी
जो एथिक्स बाउंड्रीज हैं, एथिकल जो
बाउंड्रीज हैं उनको भी क्या करना है?
क्रॉस नहीं करना है। कि ओके? ईगो
प्रॉब्लम, एटीट्यूड प्रॉब्लम्स ऐसे कैसे
कर सकता है? नो उसके साथ ना कोई
आर्गुमेंट। उसको कन्वस करने की कोशिश नहीं
करनी है। दोबारा से कॉल बैक नहीं करना है।
परेशान नहीं करना है। कोई अलग एक्सक्यूज
मत ट्राई करो। क्योंकि आपने एक स्टोरी
बनाई थी। आप स्टोरी में फेल हो गए। सामने
वाले ने रिजेक्ट कर दिया। इसका मतलब यह
आपकी साइड से मैनपुलेटिव नहीं है। यह आपकी
लिस्ट से आउट है। अंडरस्टुड? पॉइंट नंबर
वन? सबसे पहले बाउंड्री का पता चल गई। अगर
इंगेजमेंट में किसी एंप्लई ने आपसे मना कर
दिया, फोन कट कर दिया, आपको रिप्लाई नहीं
दिया या रिप्लाई में भी वो इंफॉर्मेशन
देने से मना कर दिया तो फिर आपको उस पर
ट्राई नहीं करना है दोबारा। अंडरस्टुड?
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
पॉइंट नंबर वन यह था। चले पॉइंट नंबर टू
पर।
पॉइंट नंबर टू पर चले। चलिए।
पॉइंट नंबर टू है आपका कि
पब्लिक जो इंफॉर्मेशन होती है वह आपके
स्कोप में होती है। लेकिन उनके जो पर्सनल
अकाउंट्स होते हैं वो आपके स्कोप में नहीं
होते। कहने का मतलब क्या है कि आप उनकी
पब्लिक सोशल मीडिया पोस्ट को देख सकते हो।
प्रोफाइल बिल्ड कर सकते हो। ठीक है? वहां
से आप अपनी इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कर सकते
हो। बट आप उनके पर्सनल अकाउंट को टारगेट
नहीं कर सकते। उनका जो पर्सनल अकाउंट है
वह क्या है? आउट ऑफ बॉन्ड आपके लिए।
पर्सनल अकाउंट का मतलब क्या है? उनकी जो
प्राइवेट प्रोफाइल है या जो उनकी
रिस्ट्रिक्टेड पोस्ट है जो उनके पर्सनल
फोटो हैं। आप उनका यूज नहीं कर सकते। उसको
अवॉइड करना पड़ेगा। उनको डीएम नहीं कर
सकते। फ्रेंड रिक्वेस्ट भेजना या उनको
प्राइवेट मैसेज भेजना यह आप नहीं कर सकते।
फ्रेंड रिक्वेस्ट नहीं भेज सकते। आप
कनेक्शन बनाने की कोशिश नहीं कर सकते। कोई
प्राइवेट मैसेजिंग ऐप का यूज नहीं कर
सकते। जैसे WhatsApp है, Telegram है या
एसेट्रा है कि मतलब पर्सनली उनसे जो उनकी
पर्सनल डिटेल्स के बेस पर पर्सनली कनेक्ट
करने की कोशिश नहीं कर सकते। दूसरा
दूसरा क्या है कि हां उसकी पब्लिक
प्रोफाइल देख के आप इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट कर
सकते हो। प्रोफाइल बना सकते हो। बट आउट ऑफ
स्कोप क्या है आपका? ओनली उसका पर्सनल
अकाउंट उसका पर्सनल डाटा आपके लिए आउट ऑफ
स्कोप है। ठीक है? उसके पर्सनल
जो डिटेल्स है, उसकी जो प्राइवेसी है, वह
आपको मेंटेन करनी है। बाकी हो सकता है कि
उसकी पोस्ट पर कंपनी से रिलेटेड कोई
इंफॉर्मेशन है, कोई प्रोजेक्ट से रिलेटेड
इंफॉर्मेशन है, वह उसकी पर्सनल नहीं है।
वह उसकी पर्सनल नहीं है। उसकी पर्सनल है,
उसकी पर्सनल लाइफ। लेकिन कंपनी से रिलेटेड
अगर वह डाटा है तो फिर वह पर्सनल नहीं है।
समझ में आ गया कि पब्लिक इंफॉर्मेशन आप
कलेक्ट कर सकते हो। मीडिया, सोशल मीडिया
सब कुछ देख सकते हो। प्रोफाइल बिल्ड कर
सकते हो। बट उसमें आपको ध्यान रखना है कि
आपकी लिमिट क्या है? आपकी लिमिट है कि
कंपनी से रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन आपके पास,
आपके टारगेट से रिलेटेड इन आप कलेक्ट कर
सकते हो। बट उसको पर्सनली टारगेट नहीं कर
सकते। अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन पॉइंट नंबर टू
ओनली पब्लिकली अवेलेबल इंफॉर्मेशन इज
यूज्ड। पर्सनल अकाउंट्स आर नॉट टारगेटेड।
दे आर स्ट्रिक्टली प्रोहिबिटेड। या हम बोल
सकते हैं दे आर स्ट्रिक्टली आउट ऑफ स्कोप।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
समझ में आई बात?
समझ में आई बात सबको?
तीसरी चीज क्या है? बाउंड्री एस्टैब्लिश
करते हैं। करते वक्त रिस्पेक्ट पर्सनल
टाइम।
आपको उनके पर्सनल टाइम का रिस्पेक्ट करना
है। जो कंपनी के जो एमंप्लाइज है उनका जो
पर्सनल टाइप है पर्सनल टाइम कौन सा होता
है?
आफ्टर वर्क आवर मतलब फॉर एग्जांपल कंपनी
का वर्किंग आवर क्या होगा? मॉर्निंग 8 टू
शाम को 5 मतलब मॉर्निंग 8 टू 5 या शाम को
5 टू मॉर्निंग 8 होगा। नाइट शिफ्ट डे
शिफ्ट। तो उसी के अकॉर्डिंग आपको क्या
करना है?
उसी के अकॉर्डिंग आपको क्या करना है कि
उनको
रिस्पेक्ट करना है। उनका जो पर्सनल टाइम
है उसमें आपको कोई भी वर्क कॉल नहीं करनी
है। ना कोई मैसेज करना है, ना कोई
डीएम करना है, ना कोई फ्रेंड रिक्वेस्ट,
ना कोई फॉलो करना है, ना कोई वर्क रिलेटेड
बात करनी है। मतलब जब वह ऑफिस में होंगे,
जब वह वर्किंग हावर्स में काम कर रहे
होंगे। देन ओनली आपको उनके साथ इंटैक्ट
करना है। उनके पर्सनल टाइम को डिस्टर्ब
नहीं करना है। ठीक है? मतलब आप जो उनका
वर्क प्लेस है वहां पर आप अटैक ट्राई कर
सकते हो। लेकिन जब बात आ गई एंड ऑफ द वर्क
डे दिन खत्म हो गया। आपकी इंगेजमेंट भी
वहीं पर उनके लिए आज के लिए खत्म होगी। कल
फिर से आप दोबारा उस पर ट्राई करोगे।
लेकिन उनका जो पर्सनल टाइम है उसको
डिस्टर्ब नहीं करना है। आउट ऑफ द जो
वर्किंग आवर्स है आप उसके पीछे उनके
टेस्टिंग नहीं कर सकते क्योंकि सोचिए अगर
आप घर पर हो आप ऑफिस से काम ऑफिस से आ गए
हो यू आर रिलैक्स विद योर फैमिली आप एंजॉय
कर रहे हो कहीं पर घूम रहे हो कोई आपको
अगर ऑफिस से रिलेटेड काम से कौन करेगा हाउ
यू विल फील आपको कैसा महसूस होगा कैसा
आपको फील होगा कैसा आपको फील होगा बैठ
गुस्सा आएगा एंज एंग्जायटी होगी बुरा
लगेगा
हो सकता है आप गाली दो सामने वाले को तो
सेम सेम चीज आपको उनके पर्सनल टाइम की
रिस्पेक्ट करनी है।
जगत गुरु जी मैंने आपको बताया कि अगर
पर्सनल अकाउंट का कंप्लीटेड इंफॉर्मेशन है
तो फिर वो उसकी पर्सनल इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं
है। वो कंपनी की इंफॉर्मेशन है। वो आप यूज़
कर सकते हो।
अंडरस्टुड?
समझ में आ गई कि बाउंड्रीज कैसे करनी है
आपको।
नेक्स्ट बात करते हैं अभी
लीगल कंसीडरेशंस।
लिगल लीगल कंसीडरेशंस मतलब स्पुफिंग और
रिकॉर्डिंग। क्योंकि आप स्पूफिंग और
रिकॉर्डिंग का यूज करते हो जब
तो सबसे बड़ा चैलेंज है स्पूफिंग और
रिकॉर्डिंग का। कैसे? स्पोफिंग और
रिकॉर्डिंग से पहले बात करने से पहले आपको
एक चीज का ध्यान रखना है कि सबसे बड़ी
सबसे बेस्ट प्रैक्टिस होती है कि हमेशा
आपको कंपनी एसेट्स को टारगेट करना है।
हमेशा आपको कंपनी एसेट्स को टारगेट करना
है या हमेशा आपको उन्हीं एसेट्स को टारगेट
करना है जो क्लाइंट कंपनी के हैं। अगर
क्लाइंट कंपनी का स्मार्टफोन है उसको
टारगेट कर सकते हो। लेडन फस को टारगेट कर
सकते हो। लैपटॉप को टारगेट कर सकते हो।
उनके डेस्कटॉप्स को, सर्वर्स को टारगेट कर
सकते हो। मतलब आप क्लाइंट साइड जो एसेट्स
हैं, क्लाइंट कंपनी के जो एसेट्स हैं, ठीक
है? या जो कंपनी की जो प्रॉपर्टीज है,
उनको आप क्या कर सकते हो? टारगेट कर सकते
हो। बट बट एंप्लई के जो पर्सनल डिवाइसेस
हैं, बीओ आईडी ब्रिंग योर ओन डिवाइसेस।
चाहे उसका खुद का स्मार्टफोन हो, उसका
पर्सनल लैपटॉप हो, उसके स्मार्ट वॉच हो,
चाहे उसका होम नेटवर्क ही क्यों ना हो,
उनको टारगेट नहीं करना है। यह आउट ऑफ
स्कोप होता है। ऑफ लिमिट है। हिल स्कोप
क्या है? कंपनी के चाहे कुछ भी हो,
स्मार्टफोन हो, स्मार्ट वॉच हो चाहे कंपनी
ने कुछ भी दिया हो या कंपनी ने लैपटॉप
दिया है। कंपनी का लैपटॉप है। वह घर पे
यूज़ कर रहा है। आप यूज़ कर सकते हो। उसको
टारगेट कर सकते हो। लेकिन उसका पर्सनल
लैपटॉप है। कंपनी के नेटवर्क से वह कनेक्ट
नहीं करता। कंपनी से के साथ वह मैनेज नहीं
किया जा रहा तो आप उसको टारगेट नहीं कर
सकते। फिर आप उसको टारगेट नहीं कर सकते।
अब बात आती है स्पुफिंग की।
स्पुफिंग की बात करें तो जो स्पुफिंग है
कई जगह पर जैसे हम बात करें यूनाइटेड
स्टेट्स की यूनाइटेड स्टेट ऑफ नेशन यूएसए
की। यूएसए की कुछ ऐसी स्टेट्स हैं जहां पर
कॉलर आईडी स्कोप करना इललीगल है।
कॉलर आईडी
कॉलर आईडी स्कोपिंग
कॉलर आईडी स्पोपिंग क्या है आपका इललीगल
है गलत है ठीक है मतलब
मतलब मतलब यह है कि अगर जहां पर कॉलर आईडी
स्कोपिंग इललीगल है। लेकिन अगर आपके पास
क्लाइंट अप्रूवल है अगर आपके पास क्लाइंट
अप्रूवल है आपके पास प्रॉपर ऑथराइजेशन है।
तो फिर आप क्या कर सकते हो? उसके लीगल
स्कोप के अंदर ही लीगल स्कोप क्या होगा
आपका? जो कंपनी है कंपनी के एनवायरमेंट
में जितने भी डिवाइसेस होंगे जितने भी
कम्युनिकेशन डिवाइसेस या हम बात करें
जितने भी टेलीफोंस होंगे या जितने भी
मीडियम्स होंगे कम्युनिकेशन के ओनली आप
कंपनी एसेट्स को ही क्या कर सकते हो स्पुफ
कर सकते हो उसके बाहर आप नहीं कर सकते
मतलब आपको अपना रूल्स ऑफ इंगेजमेंट से
बाहर नहीं जाना है मतलब इसका मतलब यह है
आपके पास अगर प्रॉपर अथॉरिटी है ऑथराइजेशन
है तो विद ऑथराइजेशन आप स्कोप के अंदर अगर
आप स्पोफिंग परफॉर्म करोगे और जहां पर
स्पोफिंग अलाउड भी नहीं है तो फिर आप सेफ
हो आप पर कोई लीगल एक्शन नहीं होगा लेकिन
जहां पर स्पोफिंग अलाउड नहीं है आपके पास
कोई ऑथराइजेशन नहीं है या फिर आपके पास
ऑथराइजेशन है आउट ऑफ स्कोप जा रहे हो रूल
ऑफ रूल्स ऑफ इंगेजमेंट को तोड़ रहे हो तो
फिर आप पर लीगल एक्शनंस हो सकता है फिर आप
पे क्या हो सकता है लीगल एक्शन हो सकता
होता है। नेक्स्ट बात करते हैं सबसे
प्रॉब्लमेटिक एरिया सबसे बड़ी बड़ा पंगा
होता है किसका? कॉल रिकॉर्डिंग का। ठीक
है? कॉल रिकॉर्डिंग का सबसे बड़ा पंगा
होता है। क्योंकि बहुत सारी ऐसी स्टेट्स
हैं, बहुत सारी ऐसी कंट्रीज हैं जहां पर
कॉल रिकॉर्डिंग के
जो कानून है, वह वैरी करते हैं। अलग-अलग
टाइप के कानून है। जैसे कि किसी कंट्री
में सिंगल पार्टी कंसेंट चाहिए। किसी
कंट्री में टू पार्टी कंसेंट चाहिए। किसी
कंट्री में खुद का ही कुछ है और किसी में
लॉ क्लियर नहीं है। उनके लोकल रूल्स हैं।
ठीक है? मतलब यह सबसे बड़ा पंगे वाली बात
है। सिंगल पार्टी कंसेंट क्या होता है कि
ओनली वन पार्टिसिपेंट कंसेंट इज
रिक्वायर्ड टू लीगली रिकॉर्ड द कॉल। मतलब
क्या है कि दोनों में से किसी ने भी अगर
एक ने हां बोल दिया, कंसेंट दे दिया,
परमिशन दे दी तो वह लीगल है। मतलब आप उसकी
कॉल रिकॉर्डिंग कर सकते हो। इललीगल नहीं
है। आप पर कोई एक्शन नहीं होगा। अगर किसी
कंट्री में टू पार्टी कंसेंट है मतलब टू
पार्टी कंसेंट का मतलब क्या है कि दोनों
की कॉलर की भी और रिसीवर दोनों की कंसेंट
होना जरूरी है। सुनने वाला भी या
सुनाने वाला भी या उसमें जो भी प्रेजेंट
है जो या वह कॉन्फ्रेंस ही क्यों ना हो
सबका कंसेंट जरूरी है। अगर दोनों पार्टीज
का कंसेंट नहीं है। दोनों में से किसी ने
एक ने भी मना कर दिया तो फिर वह कॉल
रिकॉर्डिंग परमिबल नहीं है। वह कॉल
रिकॉर्डिंग आप नहीं कर सकते। जहां पर
मिक्स्ड और वेरियड लॉ है वो आपको
पता करना पड़ेगा। कंपनी टू कंपनी वेरीरी
करता है। एरिया टू एरिया वेरीरी करता है।
यह आपको खुद से ही समझने पड़ेंगे। खुद से
ही एक्सपीरियंस के साथ पता चलेगा। तो एक
यह चीज थी जो सबसे बड़ी प्रॉब्लमेटिक होती
है। तो ऐसे ही आप कॉल रिकॉर्डिंग करने के
लिए मत बैठ जाना। ठीक है? ऐसे आप कॉल
रिकॉर्डिंग करने के लिए मत बैठ जाना। अब
एक सवाल है कैन ए कंपनी गिवन परमिशन टू ए
हैकर टू रिकॉर्ड इट्स एम्प्लाइज कॉल और
नॉट? अब यह सबसे बड़ा प्रॉब्लमेटिक सवाल
है कि इस सवाल का जवाब किसी के पास नहीं
है क्योंकि
कंपनी पर डिपेंड करता है कि वह किसी भी
पेंटस को अपने एंप्लाइज की कॉल रिकॉर्डिंग
के लिए परमिशन देगी या नहीं दोगी या
ऑथराइजेशन देगी या नहीं होगी। चलिए मैं आप
लोगों से एक सवाल पूछता हूं कि फॉर
एग्जांपल
फॉर एग्जांपल आपका जो क्लाइंट है
क्लाइंट आपको बोलता है कि
कॉल रिकॉर्ड करो आप। ठीक है? आपको कॉल
रिकॉर्ड करने को कहता है। क्लाइंट
रिक्वेस्ट फोन कॉल्स बी रिकॉर्डेड
ड्यूरिंग द असेसमेंट। कि आप असेसमेंट के
दौरान
कॉल रिकॉर्ड कर सकते हो
तो आप क्या करोगे?
मैं आपसे सवाल पूछ रहा हूं कि अगर आपसे
क्लाइंट ने बोला कि आप कॉल रिकॉर्डिंग कर
सकते हो या आप अपनी असेसमेंट के दौरान कॉल
रिकॉर्डिंग करो। ठीक है? आपको कॉल
रिकॉर्डिंग को कहा। कॉल रिकॉर्ड करने के
लिए कहा तो आप क्या करोगे?
लास्ट टॉपिक आज का मतलब कि आज इतना ही
डिस्कस करेंगे। उसके बाद फिर बाद में
डिस्कस करेंगे हम। ओके? क्योंकि मुझे पता
है यह ऐसे टॉपिक्स हैं जो हम एक दिन में
डिस्कस नहीं कर सकते क्योंकि यह सारे के
सारे डिस्कशन है और डिस्कशन कभी भी एक दिन
में नहीं होते।
अगर क्लाइंट ने आपसे कहा कि आपको कॉल
रिकॉर्डिंग करना है
आपने उन्होंने सिर्फ कहा है तो सब लोग
बताओ सब लोग तो मुझे पता है चार लोग हैं
तो क्या करोगे चार के चार जगत गुरु जी आप
बताओ आप ही हो तो आप ही बताओ क्या करोगे
क्या आपको आप कॉल रिकॉर्ड करोगे नहीं
करोगे
बताइए आप क्या करोगे?
जो रिकॉर्डिंग देखते हैं वह भी इसका आंसर
कर सकते हैं कमेंट सेक्शन में।
कुछ ने बोला सर रिटर्न चाहिए 1520 वेरी
गुड बेटा ठीक है बहुत अच्छा
जी पर एक्सेप्टेड वर्बल कम्युनिकेशन
नॉट एक्सेप्टेड वेरी गुड बेटा वेरी गुड
बिल्कुल अगर आपको क्लाइंट बोलता है कि
रिकॉर्डिंग कीजिए तो ब्लाइंडली हां मत
बोलना। ठीक है? आपको क्या करना है? लीगल
रिव्यू करना है। क्या करना है? लीगल
रिव्यू। मतलब आपको क्या करना? सेम टाइम
आपका जो कंसल्ट जो लीगल काउंसिल है उससे
के साथ कंसल्ट करना है, बातचीत करनी है।
कॉल रिकॉर्डिंग के जो लॉ है उनके बारे में
रिव्यू करना है, पढ़ना है। ठीक है? उनके
बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन क्या है? मतलब
रेगुलेशंस क्या है? ठीक है? रिकॉर्डिंग
की रिक्वायरमेंट क्या है? किस-किस के
कंसेंट चाहिए, स्कोप और लिमिटेशंस क्या
हैं? ठीक है? मतलब आपका जो लीगल काउंसिल
है, आपको क्या करना? अपने लीगल काउंसिल से
मिलना है। आपका लीगल काउंसिल उसके बारे
में आपको लॉ बताएगा। उसके बारे में रिव्यू
करेगा कि कर सकते हैं, नहीं कर सकते हैं,
कैसे कर सकते हैं? सब कुछ बताएगा। उसके
बाद फिर क्या होगा? जब लीगल काउंसिल
बोलेगा कि यह कानून है, यह एक्सिस्ट करता
है। उसके बाद क्या होगा? आपका कंप्लायंस
रिव्यू होगा। मतलब कि
प्राइवेसी लॉ क्या है? क्या-क्या लॉ है?
क्या-क्या करना? क्या-क्या नहीं करना है?
उसके बाद किस टाइप का डाटा आप हैंडल कर
सकते हो रिकॉर्डिंग पे? किस टाइप का डाटा
आप रिकॉर्ड नहीं कर सकते? उसके बाद
कंप्लायंस रिव्य्यू के बाद क्या होगा?
आपका रूल्स ऑफ इंगेजमेंट रेडी होगा। मतलब
आपको क्या रिकॉर्ड करना है? क्या रिकॉर्ड
नहीं करना है? क्या आपकी बाउंड्रीज हैं?
ठीक है? आपका रिपोर्टिंग प्रोसीजर्स क्या
होगा? यह हो जाएगा। ठीक है? मतलब थर्ड
स्टेप हो गया यहां पर कंप्लायंस डिस्कशन
हो गया। कंप्लायंस डिस्कशन होने के बाद
क्या होगा? आपका क्लाइंट आपको ऑथराइजेशन
देगा। एक रिटर्न अप्रूवल देगा आप इन
एक्टिविटीज को टेस्ट करने के लिए। उसके
अंदर स्कोप और कंडीशन कंडीशंस डिफाइन
होंगी। उसके बाद उसमें रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज
लिखी होंगी। लीगल रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज लिखी
होंगी। उसके बाद ही आप क्या करोगे? जब
क्लाइंट ऑथराइजेशन लेटर आपको दे देगा।
उसके बाद क्या करोगे? आप ऑथराइज असेसमेंट
परफॉर्म करोगे अकॉर्डिंग टू द रूल्स ऑफ
इंगेजमेंट। जैसा आपने डिस्कशन किया था।
आपको पता चल गया कि इसके ऊपर कौन सा कानून
एग्जिस्ट करता है। आप लीगली क्या-क्या कर
सकते हो? क्या-क्या नहीं कर सकते? क्या
रिकॉर्ड कर सकते हो? क्या रिकॉर्ड नहीं कर
सकते? क्या आपको रिकॉर्ड करना चाहिए? क्या
रिकॉर्ड नहीं करना चाहिए। तो, यह सारी
चीजें पता करने के बाद आप क्या करोगे?
आपके पास एक रिटर्न ऑथराइजेशन चाहिए। आपको
एक रिटर्न ऑथराइजेशन मांगना है। देन ओनली
आप क्या करोगे? रिकॉर्डिंग करोगे।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
ब्लाइंडली हां नहीं बोलना है।
परने अगर पर्सनल डिवाइस है ऑफिस में लेके
जा रहा है। ठीक है? अगर ऑफिस में उसको यूज
किया जा रहा है ऑफिस परपज से तो फिर आप कर
सकते हो। अगर उसका पर्सनल डिवाइस घर पर ही
है। ऑफिस पर्पज के लिए नहीं है। ठीक है?
मतलब
आप उस पे नहीं कर सकते। ठीक है? समझ में आ
गया?
मतलब ऑफिस के लिए यूज़ होना चाहिए। वह अब
हो सकता लैपटॉप है। लैपटॉप अगर वह ले गया।
कंपनी के अंदर उनके नेटवर्क से कनेक्ट कर
रहा है। अपना काम कर रहा है। ऑफिस का सब
कुछ कर रहा है। फिर घर पर लेकर जा रहा है।
यह सही नहीं है। तो आज का टॉपिक इतना ही
डिस्कस करेंगे क्योंकि इसमें डिस्कशन करना
बहुत कुछ बच गया। मैं सोचा था कि
आज और भी कुछ डिस्कस कर पाएंगे। बट नो
चलिए फिर आज इतना ही सेशन करेंगे। ठीक है?
वरना बोर हो जाओगे। इंटरेस्टिंग लगा सबको?
इंटरेस्ट आया?
कुछ इनफेटिव था आप लोगों के लिए बताओ या
नहीं था? देखो इनफेटिव था तो सही था।
इनेटिव नहीं था तो मुझे बताओ।
इनफेटिव था ना? वेरी गुड।
अच्छी बात है। इसको कंटिन्यू करेंगे कल की
क्लास में। ओके? कल की क्लास में इसको
कंटिन्यू करेंगे। तो अभी क्लास से रिलेटेड
किसी को कोई डाउट है?
क्लास से रिलेटेड कोई डाउट है? और मुझे एक
चीज और बता दीजिए प्लीज। यह जो मैंने आपको
फीडबैक मांगा था। फिर से मैं मांग रहा
हूं। जो अभी मैंने स्लाइड यूज की है, जो
प्रेजेंटेशन यूज की है, जो मैं यहां पर यह
जो इनेटिव ग्राफ टाइप के आप सब इसके साथ
ओके हो इसके साथ आपको जो मैं आपको समझाने
की कोशिश करता हूं। आप कोरिलेट कर पा रहे
हो? या फिर वो जो हम इंग्लिश टाइप करते
हैं, उसके बाद उसको पढ़ते हैं, उसको वो
करते हैं। वो भी यूज़ करेंगे, मिक्स अप
रखेंगे।
यू आर नॉट ओके विद दैट
अभिषेक यू आर नॉट ओके विद दैट दिस जो आपको
दिख रहा है ना अभी भी यह वाला यह वाला अभी
इस टाइप से इनफेटिव
ओके डार्क थीम यूज़ करना सही रहेगा।
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं। डार्क थीम इसलिए यूज़
नहीं किया कि हमेशा डार्क थीम यूज़ करना
मुझे लगता है कि लो यह ना बोले कि क्या चल
रहा है। वरना डार्क थीम भी यूज़ कर सकते
हो। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। मैं मिक्स अप
यूज़ करूंगा सारी चीजों में। ऐसा बात नहीं
है। मुझे लगा कि वाइट थीम्स भी बहुत अच्छी
रहती हैं। इसीलिए
और यहां पर कितने लोग ऐसे हैं कि जिसने जो
₹40 वाले नोट्स की जो एप्लीकेशनेशंस है
उसका सब्सक्रिप्शन ले रखा है।
किसने सब्सक्रिप्शन ले रखा है? नोट्स के
लिए। और कोई
रिकॉर्डिंग देखने वाले भी बता सकते हैं।
तो
60 और 61 के मिल गए थे। 61 60 60 61 62 के
मिल गए थे। नोट्स अपडेट हो गए थे। चेक चेक
किया था आप लोगों ने?
आप लोगों ने एप्लीकेशन चेक की थी।
जगत गुरु जी आपने चेक की प्रणय चेक की
प्लीज चेक मैंने अपलोड करने के लिए बोला
था और यह वाले भी मैं अपलोड करने के लिए
बोल दूंगा।
प्लीज चेक उधर मैं अपलोड करना स्टार्ट कर
रहा हूं।
और जल्दी पुराने वाले भी अपलोड हो जाएंगे।
हाउ मेनी इन डेज
कैसा रे हमेशा सिखाता रहूं तो इसमें
खत्म करना जरूरी
चीजें सीखना जरूरी नहीं है।
सीखने पे फोकस करो।
चीजों का क्या है?
आपको मैं सिखाता रहूंगा। आप सीखते रहो।
बस बदले में थोड़ा सा थैंक यू। लाइक्स और
कमेंट कर दिया करो। मन करे तो आप लोगों का
कितना ज्यादा सीखोगे वो तो
मैं हूं जब तक तो बहुत सारी चीजें सीखोगे
ही।
ओके यू सी इट ओके मैं बताता हूं नितेश सर
को बोलता हूं अपलोड करने के लिए ओके मैंने
बोला था तो अगेन मैं उनको रिमाइंडर
रिमाइंड करवाता हूं। ओके तो चलो फिर कल
मिलते हैं सेशन में। ओके
अभी तो आप लोगों को एआई भी सीखना होगा ना।
कितने लोगों ने यहां पर एआई की क्लासेस कर
ली?
कितने लोगों ने कर ली?
कोई ढंग का कोर्स मिला?
एआई एपीआई
मिला किसी को ढंग का।
मिल जाएगा।
ओके चलो फिर सेशन को एंड करते हैं। बाय-ब
एंड गुड नाइट एवरीवन। सी यू फॉर टुमारो।
कल मिलते हैं सेम सेशन में। यू। कंटिन्यू
करते हैं टॉपिक को। बाय-ब एवरीवन एंड गुड
नाइट।